[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24
nayib mikati fue designado como primer
ministro del líbano
mikati es una figura política veterana
en el líbano y tendrá la labor de formar
gobierno y poner en marcha el plan
financiero que busca poner fin a la
crisis económica y también al enorme
descontento de los ciudadanos que han
protagonizado manifestaciones masiva en
los últimos meses
el presidente de túnez caixa y anunció
de manera inesperada el cese del primer
ministro de ese país también la
suspensión del parlamento y la
destitución del ministro de defensa el
mandatario argumenta que esta es su
respuesta al reclamo de los ciudadanos
que pedían la dimisión del gobierno por
el mal manejo dado a la pandemia de kobe
nueva jornada de competencias en los
juegos olímpicos de tokio 2020 el
nadador británico adam pitis ratificó su
triunfo de oro en río 2016 mientras que
el saltador de trampolín británico 'the
daily' ganó su primera medalla de oro
olímpico esto mientras las competencias
podrían verse interrumpidas por la
llegada de un tifón que afectará a la
ciudad de tokio
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález comenzamos en el líbano en
donde el presidente de ese país michelle
a un designó como primer ministro de ese
país a najib mikati quien asume el cargo
después de la renuncia de saad hariri el
nombramiento de mikati llega en medio de
una creciente ola de descontento social
que ha desencadenado manifestaciones
ciudadanas que se suman también a una
profunda crisis económica y tal bonet
corresponsal de france 24 en líbano nos
cuenta más en su reporte
la elección de nayib mikati como no
primer ministro puede dar una imagen de
cierta estabilidad muy necesaria de cara
a conferencia internacional de donantes
para el líbano que se celebrará el día 4
coincidiendo con el aniversario de la
explosión del puerto de virus sin
embargo que mikati pueda formar gobierno
se presenta como una tarea difícil su
antecesor saad hariri después de nueve
meses de intentarlo dimitió la semana
pasada
mikati representa a la vieja guardia a
esa élite política que los manifestantes
de las protestas de 2019 quería derrocar
ha sido dos veces primer ministro y
tiene una larga lista de casos de
corrupción por los que nunca ha sido
procesado el líbano lleva prácticamente
un año sin gobierno ya ha recibido una
gran presión por parte de francia la
iniciativa del presidente manuel macro
es la formación de un gobierno que dé
garantías y que ponga en marcha las
reformas políticas y económicas tan
necesarias para rescatar al país del
colapso total el líbano se encuentra en
una espiral de crisis
económica política sin gasolina
prácticamente con la moneda en caída
libre
y mientras tanto el presidente de túnez
país
zaida anunció de manera sorpresiva el
cese del primer ministro de la nación
también suspendió el parlamento y
destituyó al ministro de defensa según
palabras del mandatario la medida tiene
lugar para recuperar la paz social en el
país
túnez ha sido escenario de masivas
manifestaciones ciudadanas que exigen la
renuncia del gobierno por el manejo que
le ha dado a la pandemia de kobe 19
569 mil contagios y 18.000 decesos en un
país de casi 12 millones de personas
hacen de túnez el segundo país más
afectado por el cob y 19 en áfrica
los doctores están perdiendo las
esperanzas en el sistema de salud
tunecino pero estamos acá por nuestros
pacientes y tratamos de hacer lo mejor
que podemos en el primer caso de
coronavirus se registró el 4 de marzo de
2020 desde entonces los contagios han
aumentado sin control colapsando
hospitales y morgues
yo sé a veces tenemos entre 13 y 14
cuerpos al día pero sólo podemos
realizar 9 entierros diarios que es lo
máximo que permiten los protocolos
frente a la crisis sanitaria ha cobrado
el cargo de ministro de sanidad a 6
personas el más reciente howse y mehdi
fue destituido la semana pasada la
llegada de la variante delta que desde
finales de junio causa entre 150 a 200
muertes diarias hace que la cuarta ola
del virus sea la peor hasta el momento
según our world in their a 825 mil
personas han sido inmunizadas por
completo en el país sin embargo el
presidente de túnez caixa it
aseguró hace unos días que en las
próximas semanas un total de 5 millones
de tunecinos serán inmunizados en la
actualidad en el país rige el toque de
queda hasta el 31 de julio entre las 8
de la noche y las 5 de la mañana están
prohibidos los eventos sociales
deportivos y religiosos aunque los
ciudadanos no lo respetan mucho ante la
crisis españa francia italia china y
arabia saudita donaron vacunas y
material médico
nos vamos a perú la oposición al
presidente electo pedro castillo se
quedó con la dirección del congreso esto
después de que fuera rechazada la
postulación de una candidata por la
coalición oficialista a la tercera
vicepresidencia el oficialismo presentó
así una lista de coalición conformada
por cuatro representantes de cuatro
diferentes partidos políticos entre las
que no se tuvo en cuenta a una de las
integrantes por carecer de un grupo
parlamentario de esta forma entonces la
mesa directiva queda conformada por
representantes de cuatro partidos de
centro derecha y derecha 7 y china-
culpó a eeuu del estancamiento de las
relaciones bilaterales en texto en el
marco de las conversaciones directas de
alto nivel entre ambos países en la
ciudad de tianjin el vicecanciller de
china chen feng afirmó que washington
representa a su país como un enemigo
imaginario por su parte funcionarios de
la administración bailen presentes en
este encuentro subrayaron que el
objetivo es mantener abiertos los
canales entre washington y beijing
el controvertido pase sanitario impuesto
por francia recientemente para acceder a
lugares públicos es una medida que ya
fue adoptada por israel y china el mes
de marzo pasado ciudades como nueva york
y también la provincia de buenos aires
en argentina estudian la posibilidad de
instaurar una medida similar
el pase sanitario se extiende por el
mundo en francia ya es ley la exigencia
del documento que certifica que una
persona ha sido vacunada tiene una
prueba de code negativa o se ha
recuperado hace poco de la enfermedad
para entrar a varios lugares algunos
consideran que atenta contra las
libertades o que inhibe la libertad no
existe sin responsabilidad la libertad
en la que no le debo nada a nadie no
existe es ficción es una mentira que la
gente se dice a sí misma mi libertad
sólo termina donde la libertad del otro
empieza pero sobre todas las cosas todo
se basa en un sentido de reciprocidad
sin embargo este tipo de medida no es
exclusiva del país galo en italia el 6
de agosto se empezará a exigir un pase
similar para poder entrar a restaurantes
museos y estadios también en israel
comenzaron a aplicar medidas parecidas
desde marzo de 2021 el objetivo es el
mismo incentivar la vacunación
las regulaciones ya llegaron a américa
donde el alcalde de la ciudad
estadounidense de nueva york bill de
blasio anunció que la vacunación será
obligatoria para los trabajadores de
hospitales públicos y funcionarios del
ayuntamiento venir
necesitamos un acercamiento claro y cada
uno de nuestros trabajadores se tendrá
que vacunar o hacerse una prueba de kobe
cada semana workers caster which will en
argentina el gobernador de la provincia
de buenos aires
axel kiciloff había comunicado que a
partir del 26 de julio entraría en vigor
el pase sanitario que permitiría el
aumento del aforo en lugares como
restaurantes para personas vacunadas si
bien la medida aún no ha sido aprobada
es una iniciativa para contrarrestar el
aumento de los casos de colitis 9 por
las nuevas variantes del virus en otros
temas adán piti se convirtió en el
primer nadador británico en defender un
título olímpico con su victoria
dominante en los 100 metros braza en la
piscina de tokio nuestra enviada
especial allí a la capital japonesa
natalia ruiz nos da más detalles de la
jornada de hoy y lo que está previsto
para la agenda de mañana escuchemos
este lunes el a británico adam pit y
demostró que es imbatible en los 100
metros braza el británico de 26 años
logró revalidar su título olímpico
conseguido en río en 2016 y bueno único
rey en el sur en su categoría de estos
100 metros brasil aquí sí perdió su
corona fue creativo desde aquí de eeuu
que se esperaba volviera a ganar medalla
en los 400 metros libres pero fue
destronada por la australiana de 20 años
ariadne termos este martes bueno hay una
tifón el tifón spartak que se está
acercando a tokio ya japón y bueno habrá
seguramente algunos cambios en varias
competiciones entre ellas el surf ya que
los cuartos semifinales y finales
estaban previstos para el miércoles pero
han sido adelantados para la mañana de
este martes aquí en japón estar muy
pendientes porque hay varios
latinoamericanos en liza entre ellos el
brasilero ítalo ferreira así como luca
mesinas de
perú y bueno la noche de este martes
cerrará con algo que todos estamos
esperando y es ver a simón vados en ese
concurso de gimnasia por equipos ahí
está la primera esperanza de medalla de
la estadounidense así llegamos al final
de las noticias aquí en france24 siga
con nuestra programación buenas tardes
[Música]